uh by the way that was the stuff you
gave me last night there wasn't stuff
yes that's good she my cable was on the
show Mike was on the show before tea as
all guests should gave me a big jar of
definitely make my mom very happy mom it
was good stuff my mom was the first
marijuana smoker I knew and she had to
talk with me when I was about third
grade her talk was sprayed my perfume on
you don't tell your teachers mommy
smokes marijuana to talk with my
third-rate graders been a little
different yes daddy smokes marijuana no
it's not appropriate for children but my
mom asks me to smoke a joint with you so
you just fulfilled my mom's dream hey
Denise and it as we've always all said
it is not appropriate for children no I
don't think they should even sell
edibles in any form that well they help
sick people I will and III me didn't
only finish okay sell edibles but not in
a form that looks like a [ __ ] gummy
gotcha gotcha yeah it's just it's just
too much opportunity for I've had people
absolutely you know like is that oh
don't eat that that's a flow and like
way I would have been stoned like hey
I'm Anibal she look like they should
make it like nasty Halloween candy like
candy corn yeah uh could I ask you guys
a question yeah it was away for a minute
like what the hell happened
like talking about the Middle East
you're like yo man they should make Edel
marijuana right you're like oh you went
to the store I read this Mike came back
a sec ya know I miss something listen I
didn't smoke anything but I just want to
know if sitting here at least I'm
entitled to the Cheetos you gonna want
him after all it oh yeah I want them now
hey Isis came in and got me stoned
Richard ever but uh hey you know Richard
angle what explains Isis ability to
recruit young people from all over the
world a lot of its technology right
social media well they have space I
think of Isis like a virus right and a
virus exists because the host is sick
and the host right now right primarily
Iraq and Syria sure is like on its
deathbed but so you get the you get to
play stronger you get more stability
there Isis goes away but without social
media Twitter and the things that
attracts it that attracts it but it kind
of does this have that wasn't doesn't
matter you don't have a right now you
can put out as many you could put out an
Isis video on your show I don't suggest
you do that but right you're not gonna
suddenly have many many many more people
in this country such joining up and
signing up prices there's a limited
population it's because you have a
failed state it's because you have guns
it's because you have a civil war and a
caliphate isn't that a lot a lot of it
that they want to actually go there's an
actual country as opposed to what
al-qaeda this isn't a caliphate this is
nonsense
there's you know so again this is not
the caliphate you know really that's not
the difference between al-qaeda and Isis
is that they have an actual place that
they can say I have a place yeah they
have a territory and that's all they
have their playground to you know
practice we make any progress rolling
that back I mean they did retake really
rim not really I mean a little bit but
no in general no look young people are
getting attracted by the promise of all
those virgins little do they they're too
young and inexperienced to no virgins
are not what they're cracked up to be
Oh
you don't need to work blue yeah you're
funny as you are you know Josh green did
the media underestimate the appeal of
outsiders like Trump and Bernie duh yeah
yeah cause the only kind of a bad
question is are you people watch the
show this week but it wasn't only the
media Hillary Clinton underestimated
Bernie Sanders Oh predictions they want
to know for South Carolina and Nevada
now when is Nevada is it it's a little
different because the parties are not
the same in those states the exactly the
South Carolina comes first for
Republicans and that which first
Republican sits February 20th that's
actually so Nevada I think Bernie
Goodwin we caucus state does well in
caucus states but right
he'll also add her campaign manager used
to used to run Nevada right Harry Reid
no I mean there's a lot of Democratic
old line established is that - and
unlike unlike eight years ago she's been
organizing and knows what to do and I
think people underestimate Bernie
Sanders you know they think that because
there's all these african-americans in
South Carolina or African Americans and
Hispanics in Nevada he can't win look
you know african-americans Hispanics
minority groups we don't all think alike
it is not groupthink we're not a one big
homogeneous monolithic very voting
machine there are african-american
progressives there are Hispanic
progressives and I think he's going to
appeal to some of them I think he does
and people people are mistaken to think
he I think a lot of African Americans
have just been taught to toll the
Democratic line and I think a lot of
younger ones in particular a breaking
name you know like I say I have
african-american friends that are
conservatives that are staunch
Republicans that are independence that
are libertarians and they a lot of them
have jumped on the Bernie bandwagon just
because they're like we're not going to
a democratic line we're Tyler rhythm
system and one of those people in
particular is Shelley Winters now in
Atlanta very conservative guy had a
great talk show for Shelley winter his
name with Shelley winter the Oscar
winner no no no
no no you heard she passes leg up
Rochelle what's it say oh that I
remember everybody thought four women
for Hillary yeah what did we just see in
New Hampshire we saw all the young women
absolutely well for the old guy
absolutely yes you better you mentioned
earlier that a lot of the statistics
that are being thrown around like the
unemployment rates or total nonsense a
lot of the stuff that's being thrown
around foreign policy-wise he's total
nuts like like like Isis we're gonna
make the sand glow one per size lease
had proven cruise well where Isis
operates there's no sand uh it's olive
groves the area northern Syria it looks
like Southern California not a lot of
sand are you better you're better
printer so you can make it yellow but
it's not gonna have a lot of impact on
Isis yeah I mean the two things I said
to you that it was the caliphate and
that social media was important you see
that in the media all the time I mean we
need you the media you know it's the
fact that there is a plane armed
terrorist there was a failed state there
is this carnival where you can show up
and do horrible atrocities to people
that's the lure the fact that you know
the advertising is good is is less
important that the physical space that
exists Margaret are you concerned about
performing your stand up in a
conservative country like Singapore oh
yeah cuz I could totally get caned let
me have the guy your guy yeah I mean
it's Benedict cane for Choo I don't
she's so much gum and rose yeah I mean I
can get cane for what we just did here
tonight
we were very but rude and if he could
have wooden Giuliani have caning when he
was mayor yeah he's such a nice guy Rudy
Giuliani yeah well he may be a nice guy
he has some hard-ass opinions I mean
really to get that upset about Beyonce
he gets crabby you know I think I think
it when it comes when he sees it as an
assault on police officers I think he
gets very upset very emotional very
invested do you think it's possible I'm
just asking hypothetically to be racist
and not know you're racist
hypothetically yes I do okay but I don't
think that's the case of Rudy Giuliani
could we also agree that politicians
don't give a [ __ ] about cops that's a
lot my dad was a cop
cops are underpaid cops are under
protected when you see a cop one cop in
a patrol car that means that politicians
don't care enough to put two cops in a
patrol car to two police officers in
patrol car give the cops an opportunity
to get out of that car at interact with
community and probably citizens that
care about police officers make sure
that their liaisons between the public
and police I'm tired of the narrative
that somehow because I'm a conservative
or because I'm a Republican I care more
for police officers people who care for
police officers hire from within the
community they care about police
officers protection than their families
and you know that's just I think that
progressives need to be more assertive
I'm a gangster I'm a pan-africanist
gangster rapper and a policeman died in
southwest Atlanta and I put his picture
up no politician did that in Atlanta no
politician from his district did that so
this is totally [ __ ] to say that
because they're working-class men that
are doing the bidding of a higher class
of people that don't give a [ __ ] about
the people that they're police decide to
say
behalf of families of these often you
know politicians if you love tops you
can do a [ __ ] better job that's it
night
nice bummer speech you killed my buzz
I'm sorry all right final question wrote
will there be any blowback to Donald
Trump's criticism of Pope Francis I did
not hear what did he say oh my god
haven't heard either Oh
no well he's said in the past that the
issue about migration there should be
more of a focus on migration I thought
it boyfriends posters blogging your
stuff yeah that Donnelly tells knowing
any ideas that Donald Trump has been
about the wall in Mexico and the Pope is
going there and he's gonna meet with the
downtrodden and are they end on
conflicting paths well listen he's gone
he's gone after prisoners of war they're
both on after megyn kelly you know these
folks are like quasi deities with a
conservative base and his numbers have
gone up so he's on Twitter and the
Pope's on Twitter they could have a
Twitter war
I smell a comedy bit on the show I'll
sleep with a night over with it I was a
lousy foot walk all right time to go
thank you very much everybody
it's like another recipe